i wrote a letter
uh to the head of fox at the time
basically a plea for why they should
hire me and in the letter i said i'll do
it for free don't pay me
and uh and they didn't they took me up
on it man yeah it cost me money to do
that movie because i had to move my
newborn and my wife to atlanta for 16
weeks and uh and i got paid
what was it schedule schedule f is that
true yeah yeah they really didn't pay
you no they paid you as minimal as they
could for being the star of the movie
the lowest i could have possibly what is
that what is schedule f tell people with
schedule i got three schedule f is
off i got 32 000
for for for that movie
16 weeks in atlanta and it's probably
costing you
half that to live there oh yeah no no it
cost us it i think it cost us i ended up
factoring it cost me about 16 000 to
keep the place in los angeles move to
atlanta and you know and be there
was it a dream come true though
it was you know i it's funny man
it wasn't a perfect movie um but it was
a perfect experience how are the fairly
brothers to work with they're lovely you
know they're they're they're salt of the
earth guys they are they're the
antithesis of any sort of
um auteurs right but they still create
memorable uh um uh massively globally
impactful movies right but they do it
without any pretense they're they are
exactly what you would expect them to be
um and they're um
they were there it was it was a unique
singular and marvelous experience and
sean will and i will be forever
connected in in that regard i mean those
are the those
shawn and will if they ever call or need
anything or i i it's i'm they're they're
how did they get away with giving you
schedule f for a studio film i i've just
never heard that before schedule f is
something that you hear about with
independent movies everybody's getting
schedule f we're getting the same money
it's uh what do they call it the yeah
favorite nations are gonna say united
nations yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's the united nations same
thing yeah yeah um and it's just is is
baffling did you i mean did your agents
try to fight that
or did you just say i want this don't
even bother i was so listen man that's
crazy it's crazy it's funny right but
but how often in our lives forget about
our careers as actors but how often in
our lives are we ever faced with an
opportunity to
uh inhabit and pay homage to something
that had a massive impact on us as
children i mean to really be a part of
something you gotta understand it wasn't
like i was oh yeah i like the stooges no
no no no i had my brother for christmas
when i was 13 got me the the print of
molari and curly on the golf course it
was on my it was on my wall like i mean
i was upset i was obsessed with the
stooges so uh yeah you know i remember i
don't even remember
care when they called they're like this
is the offer i was like right yeah i got
the offer you know what i mean and as a
matter of fact
this is a good story
please this is a good story
i didn't get the offer
oh my god i can't believe this
happened i'm still remembering it
yeah so
i don't hear anything after my last
audition
i don't hear anything and then and
you're going crazy i'm going nuts and
then i get a call from from my agent who
said it looks like they want to do a
proper screen test with you sean and
will
and pete and bob are gonna do this on
the fox slot
and and pete called me and said listen
the studio is starting to waffle
on
how they feel about bringing this movie
forth
and we feel like we want to show them
exactly what we want to do so we want to
make a scene a proper scene from the
movie
and he said no pressure but this really
is he said and i said i said wait what
does this mean he goes doesn't mean you
got the part
but i want you to do this with us and
it's going to kind of live or die on if
this works so you'll get the part but if
it doesn't work we're not making the
movie so
you know no pressure so i go and you
drive the scene i'm sure mo drives all
the scenes yes
mo definitely did drive the scene and we
did the scene and it was great
but then i don't hear anything
two and a half no one calls you
but i'm dying and at this point my
stomach is like eating itself okay
and i get a call i'll never forget this
i'm driving through laurel canyon right
around here right and the reception is
for up around here thank you okay
and i get a call and i and i and it's a
3-0 number that i don't recognize and i
pull over and and uh oh is this mo and i
said yeah it's pete farrelly and i said
i said hi he goes well well what the
hell man are you doing our movie or not
and i and i was like wait what he goes
you
you you got the offer you know right
and
i said no no wait what oh oh my god
thank you and he's like call your agent
so i call my agent and my agent says
yeah well yeah no we got the offer it's
it's a shitty offer they came in with no
money and i was like wait
wait
i've been going so
my entire life i've been working toward
getting this role six months i've
auditioned for this thing 14 times and
we got the offer and you didn't tell me
well no no we were going to tell you
today and i
i i snapped snapped
and
i it was it was just this
okay you're fired it's not like
it's done you fired them i had are you
kidding how i mean
it's it's this it's your dream and
they're come on now listen i
understand and by the way i would have
loved it if they doubled the offer or
tripled it or whatever the hell it but
call me call me this is your dream this
is my dream i'm slaving in there
dying dying and it was the middle of
pilot season two where in between these
auditions i would go in and make it to
studio and not make it to network or
make it to network and i was the second
choice or make it to studio make it to
network i'm the choice and then the
pilot doesn't happen you know what i
mean so you fired them on that call it
happened right then and there you said
you're fired